what up space fam golson here from anime
upper and i'm back at it again with
another demonstrator video since
recently in the demonstrator anime we
saw tundra's demon slayer mark expand
his eyes go white and subsequently his
power increased exponentially i thought
it would be a good opportunity to trace
and explain these epic transformations
as they happen over the course of the
story if you do enjoy seeing these
demonstrator videos and want to keep
them coming you know what to do channel
the slayer within and smash that like
button with no mercy remember smash that
like button the strongest demonstrator
energy and passing is scared muzon
energy so choose wisely if you haven't
make this the video subscribe and hit
that notification bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
demonstrator videos and updates
including updates about new seasons and
while you wait for the next one feel
free to check out our huge and growing
demonstrator playlist that includes
videos on all the hashira demon moons
and much more link to that in the
description now without further ado
let's jump into its spoilers and all a
good way of tracking tundra's progress
and forms is by looking at the scar on
his forehead when the series starts
before he becomes a demon slayer there
is just a patch of pink there according
to him his forehead started to look like
that when he saved his little brother
from a falling base but tundra's dad had
like the exact same one so it suggests
tangido was destined to get it anyways
this we can refer to as sleeping mark
mode the mark changes during final
selection when tundra fights the armed
demon he gets hit into a tree and the
next thing we know he's got blood all
over his scar with this newly opened
scar with a different look he proceeds
to actually beat the arm demon the demon
who even beat sabito a character giu
singled out as being especially skilled
since pre-scar transformation tundra got
hit around and post scar transformation
tanjiro beat this insanely strong demon
it seems clear that even this early on
the changing scar was linked with
powerups or at least it served to mark
his growth and how far he's come up to
this point it's easy to miss the change
the first time you watch and i
definitely did and it could easily be
glossed over as just a coincidence but
after you come back to it knowing the
significance of the scar aka the
evolving demonstrator mark then it
doesn't seem to be a coincidence at all
anymore after all his training it seems
like tanjo's demon ceremark has awakened
through his battle with a very powerful
demon after he takes the forehead
bandages off his scar stays looking
different it looks much more like the
demon sare mark that we see on the
strongest demon slayer in history
urichi's forehead during his flashback
appearances albeit tanjoskar at this
point does look a little more jagged and
less wavy than yurichi's tundra takes
his current awaken mark on through the
rui fight where he almost beat rui with
nezuko's help but then rui took his own
head off first and giu had to come in to
wreck the lower moon and thus save
tanjon nezuko similarly tundra's mark
stays the same as he beats lower moon 1
and moo with inosuke's help during the
mugen train arc however when it comes to
beating an upper moon he needs to move
beyond this new base form and we see him
tap into that new form in this new
season the entertainment district arc
for most of the fight tundra keeps this
base for mark but in this form he can't
actually cut through upper moon sixth
quitaro's neck as we should know by now
the stronger the demon the more
difficult their neck is to cut so when
it comes down to it and tundra is trying
to cut off yutaro's head he tells
himself a single blow won't be enough he
has to summon a hundred times that
strength utero even notices the scar on
his forehead change tundra's mark
evolves and becomes less jagged and more
wavy and darker like gorici's and his
eyes go white there's a reason i
jokingly call demon slayer avatar the
last sun breather at this point he
almost seems to channel sun breeder
yurichi who's the strongest demonstrator
in history and the kind of all-powerful
avatar-like character in the series and
as an avatar tundra's eyes become all
white here and he gains this insane
strength because yorichi is such an
important figure in the story who used
the strongest breath to crush muzon in
the past he represents the pinnacle of
demon slayers and whenever a character
in some way gets closer to him like
tundra with his evolved mark it's a sign
that the character has reached a new
level in power and surely enough in this
evolved mark form tundra is strong
enough to cut off an upper moon's head
it's amazing he did something in this
form that even tangent ahashira failed
to do another thing to consider is that
while it took zaintoenosuke to cut off
doki's head tendril cuts the neck of a
much stronger gew turtle using only his
own sword unlike last time tundra's
demonstra mark doesn't stay the same but
reverts back into the old jagged one
after the battle it's sort of like he
just won super saiyan and now returned
back to his base form next let's look at
the fight between tundra and friends
versus upper moon for hantengu
interestingly enough even though he
doesn't have the e-ball demonstrator
mark active throughout the battle i did
notice that during chapter 123 on page
16 he is shown in a panel with the wavy
and darker look of the evolved
demonstrator mark the context is that he
just saved mitsuri from a deadly attack
and the implication is he summoned extra
strength as when he needed to cut
yutaro's neck but this time used it to
get there in time and save
lovehashiramitsuri from a lethal wound
his mark then reverts to the jagged
lighter one suggesting that up to now
he's been able to use the evolved one in
short bursts and as needed then as
mitsuri awakens her mark and fights the
strongest clone tanjiro uses nezuko's
fire to help turn his blade red another
similarity he has with yorichi whose
blade turned from black to bright red in
battle and as if to match the power up
of the blade tundra's forehead mark
again takes up the darker and wavy look
of yorichis except this time his eyes
don't go white suggesting he has more
conscious control of it by this point in
the story this evolved mark isn't as big
of a deal anymore to him and he uses the
power to cut up one of the hatred
clone's giant wooden tentacles as he's
chasing the main body of upper moon 4
his mark reverts back to normal but not
for long after he uses a trick of
zenitsus to increase his speed he
catches up to upper moon for his neck
and now we see his mark evolve again as
he's using what he calls all his
strength to cut through it's fascinating
to reread this section again while
focusing on the marks because i never
noticed how often his mark switches from
normal to evolved and wavy before just
as he's about to cut the neck upper moon
4 turns a tide and grabs tundra by his
neck now that he's on the defensive the
mark reverts back to normal and nezuko
has to save him it only evolves again
when tundra grabs the sword that hagan
azuka fixed and that they found in the
yurichi combat doll it is possible that
this century's old blade is yorichi's in
which case it would make sense for tanjo
yorichi's sun-breathing successor to
have it anyways tundra grabs a sword
evolves the mark looking more and more
like urichi down to the earrings wavy
mark red blade and sword and cuts the
thick deck of the demon only to discover
that this is still not the real body
tundra's mark reverts to normal as he's
trying to protect nezuko from the sun
but nezuko decides to kick him in the
direction of the demon and in this way
is practically telling him to forget
about her and to go after the demon that
is threatening the lives of humans as
they speak tundra thinking that nezuku
is done for resolves to respect her
wishes and goes after the real body
which is hiding in the heart of the
giant clone with an evolved mark again
he finally slashes through the demon's
neck which is significant because a
demon enhanced genya tried to cut and
blow through the neck before and had no
luck tanjiro wins he beat the demon and
his mark reverts back to normal as he
thinks he lost nezuko luckily nezuko has
just become immune to the sun and is
completely fine so let's recap although
they didn't make as big of a deal about
it in this one tenjo does use that
evolved demonstrator mark form in short
bursts during this battle just as he
used it against kyoto the only
difference is that now he's using it
more often and his eyes don't go white
suggesting he has more control over the
form than before thus this evolved mark
form was already strong enough to cut
through upper moon 6 and upper moon 4.
but he'll need more he'll need to reach
a new level to defeat upper moon 3 akaza
just before we move on to that fight
it's noteworthy that tendril briefly
gets a glimpse into the transparent
world in this fight against upper moon 4
which lets him know that the real body
was hiding in the heart of the giant
clone this is another ability of
yorichis except yurichi is so
overpowered that he was born with it as
i mentioned the more you look like
yurichi the stronger you are and so far
tundra doesn't just have his sun
breathing earrings and red hair he also
has his wavy demon slayer mark his red
sword and his access to the transparent
world so now let's move on to the fight
against akaza and see the form that
allowed him to defeat the demon that was
too powerful for even the gifted flame
hashira rengoku when akasa shows up
tundras evolved wavy demon slayer mark
was already activated and for this fight
it stays activated which is already a
difference from how it was against upper
moon 4 huntengu where the mark kept
switching back and forth in one panel
tundra's eyes go white again and veins
appear on his face and he succeeds in
cutting through akaza's arm no small
feet the suggestion is if he could cut
through his arm he could possibly cut
through the neck as well tundra goes on
to dodge one of akaza's attacks to
akaza's surprise and to the surprise of
guil gi is watching this from the side
and thinks to himself that it wouldn't
be an overstatement to say that tundra's
ability is equal to ahashira's so when
he gets to this point in the story where
he can maintain the evolved demonstrator
mark for an extended period of time
tendril is hashira level this version of
tundra not only earns respect from gyu
but from akaza too the crazy thing is
though tundra gets even stronger during
this battle with a new form that pushes
him beyond the hashira level he's
already reached at the beginning of the
fight it doesn't take long for akasa to
reveal how much stronger he is than giu
and hashura level tangero working
together he just kicks gyu far away and
outclasses tanjiro until giu comes to
the rescue by taking off akasa's arms
before akaza can snap tundra's sword for
the first time in a long time giu is
pushed to his limit and then he
surpasses it by awakening his own demon
slayer mark he even appears to see the
transparent world and also gains access
to increased speed and power however
akaza in turn quickly adapts to gyu's
increased speed even with a powered up
gu our side can't begin to turn the tide
until tundra begins to gain access to
the selfless state akkas is usually so
accurate because he can sense fighting
spirit but in this next level state
where tundra doesn't give off any
fighting spirit or killing intent he is
able to better dodge akasa's usually
unerring blows and he can even sneak up
on him without being noticed he also
becomes better at entering the
transparent world here it's not just a
glimpse as with huntengu he can maintain
it and see through bodies if he
concentrates on the transparent world
his body is able to move faster than
ever before tundra further explains that
when he entered the transparent world he
dramatically increased the speed with
which he could predict akasa's moves and
evade his attacks akasa's breathing and
the flow of his blood become transparent
to tanjuro tendril also gets a faster
and clearer grasp of the contractions of
his own muscles he acknowledges that
akaza may be able to sense his fighting
spirit but he can probably close it off
and then aim for the upper moon's head
after akasa performs one of the biggest
flexes in the anime by punching gyu's
sword and breaking it he goes in to
finish mark you off however at this
point tundra has accomplished what he
wanted to do he closed off his fighting
spirit and thus was able to quickly
sneak up on akaza without being noticed
he takes akaza's arm before it connects
with giu we then see this new form which
is characterized by a demonstrator mark
that extends all the way between
tundra's eyes his eyes also have an
expressionless detached kind of look
which goes with the whole not possessing
fighting spirit thing the form directly
contrasts the vein popping one where you
can see the anger and exertion in his
face and in his whited out eyes giu
comments that in this form tundra's
breathing sounds different and his hair
and eyes look different too when akasa
sees this form he freaks out a dude that
always loved the idea of fighting a
strong opponent is now being told by
every fiber of his being to finish off
tundra right away since something's
changed in him and it's made him very
dangerous akasa moves to finish them off
with his final form attack guillo
notices that the speed and power of
akka's attacks is increasing again giu
tries to counter it with dead calm while
tundra thinks that he's attained what
his father talked about the transparent
world where time is passing slowly for
him the outside movements of akuzangyu
look slow giu's dead calm fails proving
it's far from a perfect offense giu
calls aku's attack inescapable adding
that akasa hit him with a hundred blows
almost all at once it's funny in the
sense that akasa congratulates giu for
still being alive and he thinks that
tundra didn't make it however tundra
actually handled it much better than gyu
and avoided being brought down by what
giu called an inescapable attack tundra
isn't sensed by akaza and so tundra has
a perfect opportunity to finish akasa
off but instead of just doing it tundra
screams that he's going to cut off akkas
head before he actually moves in to do
it this turns out to be a big flex since
even though aksa knows it's coming
tundra is able to outspeed him as a
last-ditch effort akasa tries to sense
his fighting spirit but notices that
it's gone tundra has no fighting spirit
in this state and before he can think of
how to avoid tundra's attack tanjuro
succeeds in taking his head in this form
tundra wasn't just powerful enough to
get through akasa's neck he was even
faster than upper moon 3 which is crazy
to think about he completely outclassed
marked hashiragiyu in this fight who
also attained a higher level than he
ever had before akas is the one who
names this form he thinks about how in
this brief fight tendril grasps
something that surpassed the upper
moon's own speed tenjo came at him
head-on and completely demolished
hundreds of years of the essence of
martial arts in tundra's eyes there was
no hatred or anger no malevolence or
fighting spirit akaza guessed his eyes
perceived the domain of supremacy the
upper moon has been seeking his whole
life nothing less than the selfless
state akiza thinks to himself that he
vaguely sensed that such a state existed
but even now he had failed to reach it
after this tundra reverts to his
pre-selfless state probably because his
body has reached its limit as he says
akasa's body to everyone's shock keeps
moving like the headless horseman even
though tundra did reach a level that
completely outclassed akasa here he
couldn't maintain it any longer and so
it looked like akasa was gonna win he'd
become like muzon a demon who cannot be
beheaded and crush the exhausted tanjiro
engiu however his memories start rushing
back and they help him decide to let go
of the need to become any stronger he
self-destructs instead he stops himself
from regenerating thinking that he
already lost in that moment when tundra
took his head he suffered total defeat
he can't help but appreciate tenshiro's
bold and splendid technique how he
perfectly read akasa's moves and spun in
right on the edge of control and slashed
before akasa could even launch his
attack so to summarize the significance
of that fight tundra reached a new form
that surpassed akaza but couldn't
maintain it after taking akasa's head
and so akasa still would have won if he
chose to regenerate and become a demon
immune to be heading but he decided to
happily accept defeat as his fiancee
spirit wanted him to do then tundra and
giu collapse from exhaustion when tundra
finally comes face to face with muzon
his head is bandaged from the akasa
fight so we can't see the demon stare
mark well and it's definitely no longer
making its way all the way down between
his eyes however as they begin the fight
you can see some of it peek through the
bottom of the bandages and it is the
evolved wavy version we discussed the
one reminiscent of yorichi's in this
form tundra is not doing too well
against muzon and even loses one of his
eyes to one of muzon's attacks tundra is
obviously not at one hundred percent
after zaka's a battle and furthermore
when he tries to sniff out the
transparent world he realizes muzon's
attacks are too fast so he can't
maintain his breathing properly enough
to do it thus at this point tundra is
not able to reach the same level the
same selfless state extended mark form
that he reached against akasa tundra's
mark stays the same and he continues to
get beat up by muzon until finally
muzon's blood starts destroying tundra's
cells and muzon proclaims him dead by
this point half of tundra's face has
been taken over by muzon's blood during
this period tundra glimpses an ancestral
memory that includes yorichi he learns
about how yurichi completed his
sun-breathing forms and about how he
completely crushed muzon only to have
muzon run away like a baby and avoid
yurichi for the rest of his life tundra
eventually wakes back up half of his
face is still covered in muzon flesh in
the meantime muzon has temporarily taken
out almost everyone he approaches kano
and he is about to finish her off but
then tundra appears in the nick of time
and slices off muzon's arm saving his
love interest in the process muzon sees
tundra's face and says he looks
absolutely awful he even says comically
it's hard to tell which one of them is
the demon however tundra is different
now he's unlocked a new power through
the ancestral memories musan even can't
help but see yorichi when he looks at
tangero now and even though his mark
doesn't look that extended perhaps
partially because of the spreading muzon
flesh tundra's hair and the look in his
eye do look different i've called this
form awakened tundra before so let's go
with that name in this form tundra is
clearly more impressive than he was
before he passed out since he
successfully snuck up on muzon and
effortlessly cut through his arm and of
course whenever he gives off yorichi
vibes to moves on like now you know it's
a big deal as he reveals through the
memories where he saw urichi using the
forms he noticed his own wasteful
movements he learned about how he was
off with the angle of his wrist the
footwork the intervals between breaths
he also figures out that the missing
13th sun breathing form is actually the
combination of the 12 known forms
completing a ring and repeating this
awakened tundra form has the potential
to be the strongest form to date and he
succeeds in fighting one on one with
muzon more successfully and for longer
than any other character except of
course yorichi who still is and will
remain the strongest individual demon
slayer muzon even thinks to himself that
tundra will never be urichi's equal
that's how much stronger yorichi
continues to be still muzon finds that
he's having trouble finishing off this
version of tundra and he realizes it is
because muzon himself is slowing down he
finds out that tamiya actually mixed
poisons into him including one that made
him age 50 years for every one passing
minute his body has been diverting
strength to fight the rapid aging making
him struggle in fights that usually
wouldn't pose a problem as moussan
realizes he's aged over 9000 years in
the past three hours and it's funny
sometimes in the comments some people
try to tell me that muzon is stronger
right now than he was against yurichi
because he had so much time to absorb
more humans and thus tundra at this
point might be even stronger than
yorichi was but the opposite is the case
because of tamio's mixed poisons muzon
is undoubtedly weaker and he even says
so himself when he repeatedly suggests
that tundra is nowhere near yorichi's
level the point is not that tanjuro as a
demonstrator surpasses yurichi it's that
the team effort of tanjiro tamayo all
the demons air core yorichi and more
could accomplish together what yorici
couldn't accomplish alone that being
said we will soon cover a form tundra's
final form if you will that is
potentially stronger than yurichi but
for now tundra acknowledges that he's
not as good as yurichi was and we don't
know exactly how much he's exaggerating
here but he even says he's not even as
good as his father was who also
practiced sun breathing through a dance
of the fire god and wrecked a bear at
one point too unlike yurichina's father
who could dance or fight all night
without getting tired tundra does get
tired and even has trouble accessing the
transparent world when he stops getting
enough oxygen at this point despite
lasting quite a while by himself he
needs to be rescued by iguro then the
two of them fight together and tundra
thinks to himself again that he can't
enter the transparent world since it's
all he can do to avoid oxygen
deprivation so at this point just like
muzon isn't at his best tanjuro isn't
either it's a battle of attrition
they're doing all they can to wear each
other down as much as possible until
something gives eventually muzon is
pushed so far his centuries-old wounds
caused by orichi begin to appear on his
body guiding everyone to his weak spots
even if they can't gain access to the
transparent world for muzan yurichi was
the real monster na muzan himself so the
fact that he still thinks like this
obviously confirms that yorichi was
stronger than any of tunjuro's demon
slayer forms but the big difference with
the final battle is that because of
tamiya's mixed poisons muzon is getting
weaker and can't divide to escape as he
did against yurichi furthermore tundra
did not just fight by himself but had
help this final battle isn't about who
has the strongest final form since
everyone is weakened it's rather about
persistence and our side is persistent
enough to keep muzon busy until the sun
finally comes up and muzon's big demon
baby transformation doesn't save him
either however i did speak about another
final tundra form and it is the
strongest musa knew it was over for him
so before he passed away he turned
tanjoro into a demon into the next demon
king to be specific muzon poured all his
blood and power into tanjuro why because
he wanted tundra to be his successor
instead of yurichi's also tundra is
special because as muzon knew he could
conquer the sun and become the strongest
demon ever because he shares nezuko's
blood and she conquered the sun muzon
knows tundra can do it too and the fact
that he uses the same breathing style as
that monster yarichi ak the strongest
breathing style also lends to the idea
that tundra can become the strongest
demon ever after all the strongest upper
moon was one that could use a breathing
style and not even a breathing style as
good as sun breathing at this point
tundra becomes a demon and his
demonstrator mark has spread again the
mark goes between his eyes and even
lower plus there is another mark
developing from his right cheek since
the demonstrator mark covering more
surface area on his face has usually
meant more power it's reasonable to
assume that tundra is stronger than he's
ever been the mark briefly begins to
revert as tundra is being burnt by the
sun but then he gains immunity to it and
not only does the demonstrator mark
spread diagonally across his face going
even through his eye until it's all by
touching the one on his right cheek we
also see one develop on the right side
of his forehead too and when i say right
i mean his right as one would assume
this final demon form of tundra is
unbeatable through physical force in
direct contrast to muzon the sun has no
effect on him and neither do bright red
blades he has no weakness and even if
the slayers could cut off his head which
there's no guarantee that they could
it's all by guaranteed demon king tundra
could grow it back if muzon akaze and
kokushibo all had the potential to do it
then you can bet that this strongest
demon ever could do it too so we have an
unbeatable sun breathing immune to the
sun demon king it's straight up stated
by giu that since sunlight and bright
red blades won't work there's no way to
kill tanjiro we see bony whips appear
from his back like he's doc ock and
these are similar to muzon's whips that
he used to fight tangero even launches
energy blasts reminiscent of naruto biju
balls from his mouth probably a sneak
peek into the potential of his blood
demon art that would no doubt develop
much further if tundra actually wanted
to keep being a demon but even just this
glimpse into his potential is insane too
since it's like he just came from a
different series that's how opie he is
the ball grows in size as it heads
towards its target and even releases
lightning-like shock waves too
furthermore nezuko put her hand in the
way of it and giu realized that tundra
is holding back because she's still
alive so this was actually a nerf to
bijoubal attack eventually kano comes
and injects the medicine that along with
friendship and tundra's own principles
allows him to turn back into human
interestingly enough tundra's mark
reverts back to the evolved wavy
urichi-like one rather than to the
jagged one he had before even though he
won't really need to fight anymore at
this point tundra has lost the use of an
eye and an arm which since this isn't
one piece does actually suggest that his
character has been nerfed just think
about tangent in his own retirement so
unlike some shonen series tundra is
actually weaker at the end but it
doesn't really matter since his goal
wasn't to keep getting stronger and
stronger but to save his sister stop
moves on and then to live a simple happy
life and he accomplished all that side
note in the initial release of manga
chapter 204 tundra was shown using both
arms to clean and eat in the end but for
the volume released the mangaka fixed
this mistake and apologized for it so if
you see him using his arm in one version
of this chapter online just keep in mind
it was a mistake and tundra's arm hasn't
been miraculously healed so we saw of
tundra's forms and the powers he had
access to while in those forms
as a slayer when he entered a selfless
state against akazan his mark grew until
it was between his eyes that was one of
the strongest demon slayer forms he
entered and although awakened tundra got
useful information from his ancestral
memories that made his son breathing
better for most of if not for all the
final fight he couldn't get enough
oxygen to fully enter the transparent
world and selfless state we thus didn't
really get to see tundra at his best
against muzon but to be fair muzon
wasn't at his best either and it was an
interesting move on the mangaka's part
to make it a battle of attrition where
everyone could help rather than making
it a one-on-one between each character's
final form which is what happens often
in other shonen it's not really
debatable though that tundra's strongest
form was demon king tanjuro and keeping
with the more marx equals more power
formula more of his face was covered
with marks than ever before he even
developed at least two other marks while
his initial one grew longer than ever
before this form as i mentioned earlier
had the potential to surpass even
yurichi because yurichi's red blade and
the sun would have no effect on this
tanjiro we have every reason to believe
that he could have regrown his head so
he would have been unbeatable in
contrast he just scratches yorichi once
and the demon poison would go to town on
yorichi's body slowing him down from
within i admit i'm not 100 sure what
would happen if yurichi faced tanjuro
and it might take a long time for tundra
to scratch yorichi but as an immortal
he's got nothing but time not to mention
if tundra for whatever reason actually
committed to being a demon like
hokushibo it would have been interesting
to see how blood demon enhanced sun
breathing would look would he just be
launching many suns all over the place
with his slashes that go on to explode
the possibilities are endless he could
even surround the entire area in an
exploding sun since his opponent would
die and he could probably regenerate but
yeah that is it for all of tundra's
forms and their powers let me know what
you thought of the way that the mangaka
handled power-ups in this series as a
guy very used to super saiyan like
power-ups i thought the way demonstrator
handled them was pretty refreshing and
let me know your thoughts on how a
yurichi vs demon king tundra fight would
look in the comments who would win and
how anyways if you did enjoy this video
and want to keep them coming you know
what to do channel the slayer within and
smash that like button with no mercy
remember smashing that like button is
strongest demonstrator energy and
passing is scared moose on energy so
choose wisely if you haven't make this
the video subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
demonstrator videos and updates and of
course that includes updates about
upcoming new seasons and while you wait
for the next video to drop feel free to
check out my huge and growing
demonstrator playlist that includes
videos know the hashida demon moons and
much more link to that is in the
description and until next time see ya
space cowboys